hmm close your eyes for a second okay as
you close your eyes I'm gonna tell you
what I'm about to do I'm gonna hide on
the graphs and then I'm gonna make it
reappear and I'm not gonna tell you
which one is which okay and then when
you have a look at the graph when I tell
you the open your eyes I want you to
tell me which one you're looking at and
how did you know okay so keep your eyes
shut okay you can open them now now this
is one of the graphs I'm not going to
tell you which one it is it's either the
painter won or it's this one that we
just did which one do you think it is
well you reckon well who agrees it will
Mike was Twitter X oh that's that's
that's what a dog moved guys okay so you
guys don't think it's the painter right
so therefore I'm going to ask you
everyone disagreed you've seen pretty
Bolton like no one was even like ah
maybe so why do you think this is the I
mean what why why is my question to you
why do you think is the pantograph sorry
just before you give your answer I'm
just going to say to all of you if you
can't keep me in answer this question
you're in the same boat as will right
now right because you just flipped a
coin okay you changed your mind that's
again what okay now now I'll let you
finish your answer why do you think it's
the painted
the skin is different hold on a second
the scale is different but how did you
know that that indicated to you that
this was the pantograph and not the
other one which by the way you're
exactly right there's the painters and
there's the other one what is it about
one versus the other what tells you the
difference one of them closer into the
origin and you can tell it's closer
because of the numbers do you see that
like um what's the closest spot let me
just get rid of this guy again what is
the closest spot to the origin I think
it's around about there right can you
just look in and tell me what do you
think of the coordinates of that spot
right there just roughly seven seven
seven ish okay seven seven right now
when you put the other guy in there is
he's way closer right what would you
call that just eyeball it one one two
two it starts somewhere around there
it's the numbers that make a difference
okay so my point is to say mm-hmm now
looking at your graph how do I know
right now which one this is the answer
is I have no clue I don't know which one
it is because I don't know is that seven
away is it one or two away so you and I
we need to put some extra information on
this graph okay so here's the last bit
I'm gonna ask you to do we try x equals
zero didn't work I want to try a value
like x equals 1 if X equals 1 what
should y equal this is the graph we're
looking at right now
it'll equal 2 right because y equals 2
over 1 which is 2 okay so that means if
x equals 1 and y equals 2 that is a set
of coordinates I can put onto the graph
does this make sense so let's put that
on that's 1 comma 2 can you find where 1
comma 2 should be on your page and go
ahead and draw it on you need to be
careful try and put some decent scale on
there I'm placing mine roughly there
okay you okay with that like you want it
to be doesn't like to be super ultra
accurate but so long as it's in roughly
the right spot and please label it as
well okay now you can actually just just
put it somewhere else it's on the graph
okay it doesn't have to not each one of
those has to be one point you know or
one unit
now have a look at this guy right you
see this can't possibly be the
pantograph anymore why because we've
locked it in in fact if you've got
another color there we actually because
of the function of this point we give a
name we call this often a point for
scale because it's a point and that's
exactly what it gives us it tells us how
big or how small or how tiny this thing
is okay what do you see that's in common
come on share some things out we've
already drawn like three of these today
right
what is this having come with all the
other ones it's still a hyperbola right
in fact every single graph in this
exercise is a hyperbola surprise
surprise okay another thing that similar
is have a look vertically up and down do
you see it as a value it gets closer and
closer and closer but never gets there
what y-value is that have a look have a
look that's y equals zero you never get
there right no matter how big X gets X
can get huge and Y just gets small but
it never gets zero okay but there's a
difference let me put it on for you it's
this visit it is an intercept right for
y there and also importantly have a look
at this guy see this red line you see
that this is the vertical asymptote the
place where it's not allowed to go why
is it negative one what's the problem
with negative one here's the function
right yeah you put a negative one and
this thing becomes zero and the thing
explodes okay so that is something that
I want you to take on when you do the
rest of the question one
whenever the denominator zero that's
when you get a problem okay thank you
very much you're 11 you worked hard